maintenant sur la situation dans la
capitale à kiev retrouver notre envoyé
spécial bastien renouil bonjour bastien
vous trouvé autour de kiev les
ukrainiens ont réussi à résister aux
russes et à les éloigner de la capitale
mais l'ennemi a laissé des traces vous
suivez notamment des opérations de
déminage
tout à fait oui à plusieurs kilomètres
au nord de kiev j'étais avec une équipe
durant toute la matinée une équipe de
militaires qui tentent de déminer et
bien les environs nous étions aux
alentours dans le pont un pont qui a été
détruit par les russes lors de leur
retraite vers la biélorussie ils l'ont
fait exploser avec des caisses de
mortier dans lesquelles ils ont mis des
détonateurs et une fois que ce pont et
est en ruine et bien ils ont de nouveau
cachet des mortiers ils ont caché des
mines antichars sous le pont de manière
à blessé et a tué les militaires
ukrainien qui viendraient déblayer les
décombres pour tenter de reconstruire de
nouvelles infrastructures et non
contentes kg ce point ils ont aussi
ajouté des mines antichars tout aux
alentours des dizaines de mines antichar
qui vise à faire sauter les camions
ukrainien qui viendraient ici installer
des infrastructures temporaires ça c'est
pour ce qui est de la route des
infrastructures de transport et c'est la
même chose dans toute la région à me
disais les démineurs et puis il ya aussi
la composante civile de très nombreuses
mines antipersonnel un petit peu partout
dans la région je parlais avec des
fermiers qui me disait avoir retrouvé
des mines antipersonnel dans leur
chambre ils n'ont pas le choix me
disait-il il faut absolument pouvoir
manger c'est la saison de planter les
pommes de terre ici ils sont si
importantes en ukraine et donc eh bien
il retournait quand même la terre chaque
jour pour pouvoir les plantes et malgré
le risque au risque qu'ils sont obligés
de prendre me disait-il